[Music]
what's up everybody lauren sovereign
coming to you live from day three of
taxis 2022 for lords of gaming.net and
the iron lords podcast i'm standing here
with jm at the devolver digital booth
and we're going to talk about cult of
sure cult of the lamb is a uh it's a
combination roguelite adventure game and
uh village sim builder you are an
adorable lamp who uh is about to be
sacrificed to prevent a dark age from
consuming the world but luckily just at
the moment of your death the one who
awaits your new dark god resurrects you
and brings you back to life empowers you
with the crown of
the one who waits i guess and uh gives
you the opportunity to build a cult of
your own and that's i mean that's the
gist of the game you you have a cult you
build homes for them you build farms for
them you build latrines for them can i
say [ __ ] on this
otherwise they [ __ ] everywhere otherwise
they [ __ ] everywhere
and when you need resources you go out
into the world and uh and you gather
those resources take them back to your
village build your village go out into
the procedurally generated world fight
bosses by monsters etcetera etcetera and
infinite until you bring about a dark
age that consumes the world
so your goal is to prevent the dark ages
from consuming the world that has to do
with your death
and bring it up bring it upon the world
in the way that you want to do it there
are four other dark beings and they're
trying to prevent your dark god from
destroying the world and uh your dark
god prevents them from doing so it
empowers you to destroy them hopefully
if you're good enough to do it and uh so
i think you are the only one bringing
him out in age of darkness
uh two totally different questions uh i
appreciate you asking about both modes
of the game at the same time uh combat
is primarily melee you've got swords
axes that sort of thing oh
a little lamb is woken up in the nether
round between life and death that
liminal space waking and dreaming where
the dark gods can speak to us all
uh
so you go out of the world it's largely
melee you do get spells that do
different things you get of course like
like any of these things you get
different items that have different
effects and create a sort of a different
gameplay experience and then the village
is constantly in action uh there's you
know
people your people are getting hungry
you have to develop faith for them you
give sermons you give edicts you tell
them how to live their lives and if you
do need a little boost you can always
sacrifice one of your followers uh and
use their blood to fuel any dark rituals
that you may need to perform phil tell
me a lot of times i like to ask the
question what was the inspiration for
this type of game
is there anything to glean from here or
is this just the mind of a man
i can't speak for massive monster the
developer of this game um looking at it
playing it experiencing it i think it's
just about friendship
friends and love
and creating bombs yeah friendship love
creating bonds that cannot be broken
except my death except by that yeah and
say
the one who waits the one who is the one
who wins
he
should not be named
uh no
not that either the one who waits so
tell me when can we expect to go to the
lab out in the wild and on what
platforms should we expect
this year and on every current major
platform
this has been called the land for
devolver
this game looks absolutely bonkers it's
it's what devolvers is known for
publishing it is a fantastic looking
game look out for it later this year
this has been lord sovereign for the
iron lords podcast of lords of
gaming.net
[Music]